joining us now the head coach one of the
best teams in the National Football
League ten and two and off they go on
their way to the postseason and who
knows where it will win this year for
the New Orleans Saints he is Sean Payton
coach welcome back how are you good Mike
thanks for having me on hey you know one
thing I'm fascinated by and I want to
start here you had Peter King in your
team hotel a few Saturday nights ago and
you know how other coaches are
everybody's so guarded everybody's so
afraid
give me your thought process for kind of
opening the door and providing access
that really gives the fans a window into
how a team finalizes its preparations
for a game yeah listen Peter had called
prior and we were talking on another
subject and the topic was Drew and his
preparation and and he said hey I'm
gonna be in town would have I you know
would I be able to get over there and
just sit kind of embedded and observe
you know the evening meetings schedule
and then how it moves to offense and
defense and then how it moves to the
quarterbacks and just to get an idea you
know you say these guys prepare you say
these guys they do so much you know and
I'm talking about those elite level
quarterbacks but it was a chance for for
someone like Peter to to see actually
what that is you know it's film study
and but here it is at the end of the
week and and and maybe I'm getting a
little softer through through the years
but look I think it is something that no
one Peter that it was going to be done
the right way and certainly without any
risk of you know the next game it was
literally the next day and all all of
the report came out the following week
so you know we it was a little unique
and yet I'm sure it's been done before
there's been plenty of talk and plenty
of focus in recent weeks coach on the
relationship between head coach and
franchise quarterback the push in the
pool - given the take it kind of came
into sharp focus in Green Bay recently
from your perspective though working
with
breeze all the way back to 2006 give us
an idea of what that's like on a day in
and day out week in and week out basis
well listen in season certainly is
different than the off season but in
season there's a there is a stress to
preparation a sense of urgency each week
of having the right plan a sense of
urgency by the quarterback of the timing
and knowing you know what are outlets
you know can we audible here what can we
get to hear each week that you kind of
wind that clock and it starts again and
on Wednesday yesterday and today it's
ticking but as the week progresses
you're more and more comfortable with
the plan you begin to see situationally
what you like and then each week you
start over again and look he's one of
these players who's got that gift to
improve those around them through his
work ethic leadership skill set and
playing ability and I think that same
thing happens with the coaches you know
our pressure our stress each night is to
make sure we've covered all the things
we've covered relative to this game have
we missed anything doing you know need
this certain route what about this run
that and then who you know where are we
putting our personnel in these positions
so it's you know when you're having
success you like anything else you don't
want to let anyone down and I think that
would certainly be at the quarterback
position that would be at the receiver
position at the running back coach or
the head coach you know you're wanting
to to make sure that you do everything
you can to give up you know give
ourselves the best chance to win and so
to the relationship there's
communication constantly relative to the
plan on the field off the field video
you know he's meeting right now probably
10 yards across the hallway from where
my offices and it wouldn't be it would
be very normal for me to walk over there
with three times maybe during this
meeting with with questions or this is
what you're thinking correct or reminder
you know that kind of thing and it's
just it's ongoing all the way up to a
game time your team had reached the
level of domination in recent weeks that
reminded me of when we were growing up
in the 70s and scores would be fifty
three to ten and forty eight to three
and and and it was going incredibly well
and then last Thursday night a pothole
emerged with the Dallas Cowboys now that
you've had a week to look back on that
game what's your assessment of what
happened that night in Dallas well I
would say this if it really unfolded
from a scoring standpoint we felt I felt
it was going to be a lower scoring game
their defense is playing good football
and I kicked myself for two or three
different situations in that game of not
really not handling them the right way
and you know we have an opportunity to
score its fourth and two and I know our
fourth down numbers are good and I felt
like we had a good plan and yet in that
type of game kicked a field goal because
III didn't feel that was going to be a
30-something two twenty-something game
at all I felt going in patients was
going to have to be you know something
that we valued ball security and we were
able to you know get the takeaways
defensively field position in the
kicking game so that we can say the
first thing I'd say is I don't want to
shortchange what I think is a much
improved Cowboys team that played won
three in a row and just won or fourth
and and they're playing exceptionally
well and then from our standpoint me of
managing that a little bit better and
you know you come away with a tough road
win and regardless of how it happened it
happened in Baltimore 21 20 you know
that type of game I just felt like it
was going to be a lower scoring game and
yet I didn't manage it the same way you
touched on a very compelling top it can
vary Tommy now in the NFL I spoke to
Doug
the Eagles coach recently about this all
the factors that come into play when
you're making that decision on fourth
down go for it or not going for to go
for it or not give us an idea of
everything that's in your own personal
stew of what influences your decision in
those moments are already option whether
or not you think it's obvious question
what all goes into great question
because this is the challenge and this
is what looking in this is what will
drive the analysts crazy and yet the
numbers and the situations relative to
the percentages are important but how do
we feel like with our play inventory at
that point in the game so if I'm inside
the 5-yard line and I've got a section
of two-point plays that let's say I love
two of these I mean I love them well
certainly I would love them enough to
score six points with them right I mean
I'm not going to as much as I love this
play from the two I'm going to wait in
case we need it in the second half for
four so I'm like hey I don't know how
many times I'm going to be inside that
five and if I if this is a two-point
play but it also is a play I like you
know we'll call it in the first quarter
to score touchdown so what's your play
inventory like at that point relative to
where you're at in the game and this
that would be more inside the five and
two point play or going for it
how's the game going you know I honestly
and I'm old-school this way I'm not
interested in that two-point chart in a
lower scoring game in the third quarter
I'm not and and so now in a higher
scoring game I'm gonna look at that
chart a little earlier and yet it still
wouldn't be well into the second half
now fourth down 38 yard line who will be
playing how are we matching up you know
I was asked the question once about a
game four years ago and why why didn't
you consider and I said well
have you looked at the matchup over at
our left tackle position and so during
the course of that game that matchup was
one where we were really struggling and
so these things that can change in game
with injury or just hey I don't like the
way this is going Lawrence Taylor has
hit my quarterback three over the last
five times we've taken a drop to throw
the football so those have to factor in
but I do think we are all seeing a
little bit more we're seeing a little
less conservative approach you know
outside of field goal range fourth down
I think that would be the one thing that
all of us as coaches think more about
maybe than the punt going in you know
the thing that always and more said
we've got a real good putter but there's
nothing worse than you're in that like
cusp and you're like all right let's
punt it and pin them back and that thing
takes one of those skips into the end
zone and then it comes out to the 20 and
you look at it you're like ah we could
have thrown an interception there I
think that's changed though why do you
think coaches are now more in those
spots no I think listen I think you're
starting to when you can put numbers
together that talk relative to your team
because you can talk on a league average
32 but you know each team is compared
differently and so I what are our
numbers and what are our percentages and
then you can you can actually put on
paper hey here's why and so I do think
that's where analytics have changed in a
positive way I mean in a good way very
because you can go through these
scenarios which we do and we've got an
analyst here and shoot each week mark
will give me a litany of things that
happen during the week with other games
you know mistakes made or maybe maybe
not and then and then the analytics of
the game we're getting ready to play and
key factors I think we're more educated
and
so much I can get to with you here and I
know you're busy I want to take a
broader look at the NFL you're on the
competition committee there was a story
earlier this week and these are quotes
from rich McKay and it's it's part of
this program to make the punts safer
they're crowdsourcing ideas there's a
lot of confusion about what's wrong with
the punt as it's currently configured do
you have a feel for why there's an
urgency to change the punt play to make
the punt play more safer and what's
dangerous about the punt in comparison
you know kickoff I I don't know
specifically I would say the one unusual
thing about the punt play and this I
think we'll see change in the next five
years it's the only play where these
Gunners potentially will literally fly
through the sidelines back up and they
get forced out of bounds and then the
jammers have to run not in the white but
wait for them to come back in the field
of play to hit them so it's the only
play where there's elements to the punt
coverage unit that are played on the
sidelines not in the field and and
you've seen you've seen crazy looks for
that that jammer goes behind three
players in the bench and pops out you
know later on down the sidelines so I
think I don't have the numbers though
statistically relative to injuries and
and I listed I saw the you know come up
with an idea and submit it and that
whole thing and and it's all good well
we'll see what they do with that coach
and we'll see how the rest of the season
goes for you wish you all the best I
know you're really busy I'll let you get
back to work
and we look forward to talking to you
again soon it sounds good
all right Mike thanks
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports